chris is in Hartford Connecticut hi
Chris welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
there how are you today sir better than
I deserved man what's up in your world
okay I've got a moral question for you
it's not so much a numbers question for
you because um I've recently found my
walk with Jesus and I went through
something with my family last year where
my sigh I'm a little emotional sir okay
well times I apologize last year I found
out that my then wife was being
unfaithful I had asked her directly for
the truth on several occasions and I
never got it until it was too late
and she couldn't reel me back in and
we've got two little kids and basically
I I don't I'm not financially obligated
to her just to keep it vague here I got
a property down the street that I rent
very involved in my children's lives
it's a 50/50 custody agreement but my
struggle has changed I'm working my baby
steps on baby steps do I've paid off
seventeen of thirty thousand and I oh
good for you and I'm making traction
very much because of your your work sir
so thank you job so the question that I
have is that my financial situation is
turned around as much as it has I don't
know where I've never been in a
situation like this in my life I don't I
don't know what is an appropriate amount
to help her because I know that she's
still working the same job I don't think
she's making any more and when we were
together she was struggling but this is
somebody who is very dishonest to me ah
randomly gets very vicious with me I I'm
I'm not trying to say that I've been
perfect sir I've got a lot of things
that I need to ask for forgiveness for
in this life but I don't think I
deserved any of that I understand so um
basically your divorce do you have any
obligation on any of the debts that she
I helped her with 100 bucks a month
towards the car
why no big whoop but that's it why is
that part of the UH divorce shuttle well
when I was broken we were splitting up I
promised her that I'd help her with it
okay so you promised her but you don't
have that in the divorce decree oh no no
I'm sorry sir yeah it's it's in the
decree oh it is in the decree okay yeah
and it's in Robert II so watch LD is
your name on the car yes okay so if the
car is not paid you've got a problem
right yet there because they're going to
come after you yeah okay are there any
other debts that she's supposed to pay
in the divorce decree that have your
name on them uh I that was the first one
that I said care of that we had a co
debt on a debt consolidation loan as you
called weren't were there any are there
any other Co debts that she is
responsible for right now my name comes
off of the mortgage off of the house
that we had together this month how
that's in writing it's legal it's we've
been working together on it so I know
it's not it's not legal your name
doesn't come off of the mortgage unless
the mortgage has been paid off or
refinanced oh it's getting refinance I'm
sorry okay alright now that that works
alright so your name comes off the
mortgage are there any other code dad's
no okay good so how much like owed on
how much is owed on her car ah
I think it was a $15,000 car is that
what's owed on the car I would have to
ask her what the balance is currently I
know that she's turned with it and never
missed the payment on it okay
um that one what I asked uh hey that's
okay the hmm how much debt do you have
in your debt snowball I've got 30 left
out of the 47 now you told me that okay
the you're making really good progress
congratulations the first thing you're
the first moral obligation and the only
moral obligation you have is to take
care of your children okay your ex-wife
is not your responsibility that's why
they call her your ex-wife
you know you have a moral obligation for
100
a month and you have a legal obligation
for $15,000 on that car if she doesn't
pay it so you got a real common-sense
obligation to make sure that gets paid
one way or another okay or gets sold one
of the two I think you're going to
concentrate on you building wealth and
being generous in general and that
includes certainly taking care of your
children and that's where I would spend
my financial energies if I were in your
shoes
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you